hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play finger bones
now there's a game that a lot of people
been asking me to play and I don't know
a lot other than that other youtubers
have played it already so it's my
weekend to get Katie but I'm not really
in the mood i distracted it with the TV
it came here to read I couldn't interest
myself in reading so I tried to write I
couldn't write anything more than the
usual handful of dissing alien thoughts
of theories medication didn't help and
divorce certainly didn't help either
that's depressing because I am not
depressed I'm enlightened this is a
result of two two decades of scientific
education and philosophical pondering
this is the price of knowledge well it's
good that we got our existentialism out
of the way and lots of use of big words
so what else is there to do this game
actually said that it recommended about
an hour or two to set aside for the
playthrough of it but I appear to be
trapped in a single room so I do not
know if over the period of about an hour
or two there's gonna be a lot of strange
things happening if that is the case
then I guess I'm gonna be playing for a
while until something happens
exit 2 I go out the ends ah ok I'm back
now we're gonna pretend like that didn't
happen did that just chew up time that I
had spent in here wandering around until
something happens because if this is a
game we're actually oh hello ok I got a
flashlight
ah so now I see is there something in
here for me to do I real I don't know
why I use my stepped out his name as a
door lock code in my survival bunker but
whatever keeps her happy I suppose she's
like her mother
a delicate fragile version of her mother
damn her
whoa dude whoa there buddy ok so the
door code to your secret bunker is the
name of your daughter which was like
Katie or something like that
Katty ka TI e Y K T so so what about
that ooh wait a minute is that a
keyboard it appears to be a page from a
manuscript op morality is too reliant on
emotions and not relying on enough
rational thought if morality must be
determined and I maintain that is a
farce it should not be determined by
feeling feelings are nebulous subjective
and changeable rather it should be
determined by thinking the actions of a
natural creature are natural and thus
moral unless a concrete scientific
reason can be given to prove that them
is immoral amoral
so this seems to be a rather deep and
interesting game filled with intricacies
I shall do my best to try to not treat
it like a pile of goo P so this appears
to be a keyboard but no no no uh-huh
that ain't gonna be it ah hoo when I was
15 year olds I lost my virginity I shook
uncontrollably the entire time I felt
that same primal excitement yesterday
night in the cellar ok good for you aha
here we go there's a door over here
hello Katie are you gonna let me put in
Katie oh ok turn on some sort of a
generator
I didn't notice he sings before because
they were like absolute pitch blackness
in the darkness oh here we go I powered
up the keyboard now I can actually put
in the key code of Katie
ka TI e capital k no ah
why isn't working oh I get it that was
the confirmation noise that it actually
did work so this door should open right
hey did I did it I did it okay now we're
getting somewhere
this looks like a Minecraft tunnel that
I built a million times over what do we
have here it's finally happened the
world the whole world is a chaos of
thunder and screams and when the ass is
settled we will all be wild animals
again I'm ecstatic beyond words I
haven't been able to reach Linh for
several days and she's probably dead for
all I know or care but Katy was here
when it started and I have no idea what
to do with her most of the town is dead
Katy and I only survived because we ran
to the bunker perhaps this is just what
I've needed freedom from all the
irrational rules and inane social values
just pure beautiful survival this guy
seems kind of self-absorbed if I have to
say so he's in his own little world here
he doesn't
I'm sorry the tool room has been her
name for years now and I can't bring
myself to change it years I boxed up
everything that isn't practical and
useful I burned all the books that
weren't for scientific education I'd
like the store the boxes in the cellar
but I can't get them down the ladder by
myself I just piled them up near the
hatch the blood would probably ruin them
and me
okie-dokie this is going great
I can already tell that this guy is
totally sane and not going to be not
going to be super bad well now that I've
explored the depths of my own madness
perhaps it is time to do something
productive like backtrack that's always
good
hi I got stupid feeling about this so is
there some symbolic meaning of you know
leaving out the exit that you can leave
anytime but you don't want to because
then the game's over and the story is
over and then there's nothing else to
tell is that what I'm supposed to
detract from all this ah I don't think I
used to track properly but I'm just
trying to make my words as big as this
guy's and a bit of thing need to be
compared ibly bigger Jonah what's this
Davin it is what Rouge
maybe I gotta go back upstairs and type
in another code okay that did a book is
that Boop important was that the same
move as Boop before cuz the only two
names I've known as his wife Lynne and
his daughter Katie so does that mean
that now I will be able to move into the
tool room hey it worked I can't believe
that actually work oh it is dark in here
shut up there are you a home yeah took a
bit to get here she remembered Father's
Day and drew me a picture I don't
understand her she's just like her
mother she wants to waste time drawing
pictures and we're barely able to find
enough food and survive
I turned to crayons in the candles we
need more candles in case a generator
goes out again and it helps break up the
monotony I yearned for the excitement of
those first weeks the excitement of
nuclear war there are things I've wanted
to do for years desires I've kept lock
in the back of my subconscious it's been
nearly a year since I've seen a woman
and now I realize there's no practical
reason to keep those desires locked oh
no you didn't you
I got a bad feeling I changed the
storage from code to something I can
easily remember and and why the rest of
the word is missing and then why that's
not a word that's nitty linen Inca poop
then and now the hell are you talking
about how is that easy to remember and
and why the rest of the word is missing
maybe that's like a code you know and
then why missing hahaha I just got a bad
feeling about all this you shut your
mouth you show your dirty rotten mouth I
got it I got it I got it and then why L
cuz Lin backwards would be denial hey
this guy had some serious hang-ups about
his family that I don't appreciate it
all oh I can't move we're gonna move did
it freeze Oh No please no no no no no no
okay I think we're back and I think I
got it in order it didn't freeze it just
stayed still for a second all right I am
a bag of DNA yes you are I exist to make
more of myself I married and produced a
daughter because my genes demand
reproduction I wrote books and created
because creativity served a survival
advantage to my ancient name ancestors I
built this pace took refuge in it and
Spencer hours thinking of silly little
artificial laws to live by because my
forefathers built cities and societies
to allow time and peace to reproduce and
to break their genes dreams loves
opinions desires beauty innocence
figments of our collective primordial
imagination fleeting electrical signals
a fire across our synapses for a
pointless moment in time they used to
serve a purpose and now they are
needless confusion and Here I am the
last man on earth for all I know ready
to be freed from them
also ready to become a psycho crazy
person not if I hope that I'm I hope I
don't hope that I'm you I just hope that
I you know don't find you here hmm I
hope that I don't find out that you're
oh hello
OOP I hope that I don't find you there
with a knife standing in the basement
naked ready to charge cuz that would not
be agreeable but not be uh I'm not down
to clown with that idea so what did i do
what did i do what is the little button
do with that little button do
maybe it's back upstairs again and that
little indentation on the wall seems to
be sending me back and forth quite a bit
in this game well I ain't havin it ah is
that a thing I think I see a thing this
indentation got bigger ha here we go the
cellar is freedom good are those finger
bones I think them be some finger bones
okie dokie so maybe the code is either
freedom or finger bones
okay that was the confirmation beeps I'm
assuming that was good okay I don't like
this I don't like this I don't like this
one bit
this guy's psycho crazy bug he's gonna
stab me and my button Amin are gonna be
happy about okay
sweet sweetie
there's only enough food for one since
she's gonna die anyway and I'm free now
freedom it's at the end of all humanity
divine freedom holy crap this guy's is
saying am i this guy am i insane Oh II
do not like this it seems to have been
torn from a diary she finally died last
night I don't know whether from
starvation dehydration or blood loss I
threw her body into the woods her
fingers my anti religious artifacts my
Testaments to moral intellectual freedom
are locked with the same upstairs I am
contented that all as I haven't done
anything wrong
are you sure about that oh the father
didn't know why he'd come back after all
these years starving and tired he just
wanted to see the seller LaHood last
time with one last video thicker the
flashlight died and he was left in pitch
dark he's got all the gold echoes alike
you can still hear it out ah that was
the end well what what what the hell
that was the ER thousand why those
finger bones everybody I'm just I'm
trying to wrap my head around what the
hell just happened because honestly I
have no idea I don't know what happened
it's all darkness inside my soul okay
anyway so that was finger bones
everybody hope you enjoyed it there's a
creep eat it that was like one
tails you tell around the camp story do
a bunch of little campers as you want
them to have nightmares for the rest of
their life it was thoroughly creepy and
actually it's one of those games that
really emphasizes the atmosphere of it
and the situation besides it because I
didn't know if I was someone coming into
that bunker or if I was actually the guy
and I was very worried that the girl
would be there and just like this
interesting tale into the mind of an
insane man or maybe he was the actually
sane one and we're all crazy for putting
up the moral rules behind us either way
it was really cool so thank you all so
much for watching if you enjoyed the
video let me know in the comments below
if you want to see more horror games I
know that people have been asking for it
please suggest me good ones people been
saying that I've quit playing horror
games that is not the case I'm just very
very very eager to find good ones and I
don't I don't want to keep putting out
videos where I'm like I just gave you a
bunch of poopy ash dicks and no I don't
want that to be so anyway thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
what's in the world